uh
uh at the uh in 1948
uh many decades later i learned that the
uh unemployment rate among black
teenagers in 1948
16 17 year olds
was
9.4 percent
among whites of the same age it was 10.2
so both blacks and white teenagers
had only a fraction of the unemployment
that they have today
uh you were expected to work you were
expected to be able to get a job and
more importantly the jobs were there for
you
uh and so and what this is because of a
fluke really the the minimum wage law in
the united states fairly understand this
act of 1938
was passed with specified
rates of pay that you're supposed to get
almost immediately
inflation took off during the 1940s
so by 1948 those numbers that were in
the law were meaningless oh i see you
know in other words when i started out
as a western union messenger the minimum
wage was 40 cents an hour i started out
at the bottom at 65 cents an hour so it
was the same as if there was no minimum
wage and this is what happened you had
this
i was so lucky i knew of course i had no
clue about any of this
now now a black kid 20 years later comes
in there
uh they've now
they've people have become compassionate
they raise the minimum wage so he can't
get a job
got it and i don't think it does any
community any good to have a whole lot
of teenage
males
hanging around on the streets with no
job and nothing to do
oh my
so many
and it's the same people you know it's
crazy these same people will say oh i'm
helping communities i'm doing this this
and this and i swear to god jess the
people that do the most say the least
the people that act like they do
everything yes bro they do nothing
even i'm so
oh
i'm thinking about something i'm trying
to like connect it to see if it would be
a thing and what i'm thinking about
is
would it
would there have been
any i won't say any but would there have
been an inflammation of crack into the
black communities if this was something
that
wasn't a thing like would that have
would that have been
an avenue for people to
make money
but
illegally and then if this was
implemented they wouldn't they wouldn't
have needed to make money legally
because they would have had the job
opportunities to work and then
there wouldn't be
it's kind of weird timing it's kind of
weird it's kind of weird timing how that
happened right around the same time the
welfare state was introduced kind of
weird timing
burned the whole country down cut
kind of weird and you know what's crazy
too i know people
um i know someone that
dealt drugs when they were younger and
you know who got him into it his
teacher bro
it was like a school
yeah i was like a gym teacher or
something wow
so it's like literally from
the system that's supposed to protect
yeah
you know what's crazy that same teacher
runs a dare program now oh bro i know
they're like yeah he changed the name
get him cancelled i don't know the name
this guy just told me that i was like
what the [ __ ]
what
imagine if that person
didn't have a change of heart how many
other
students
i don't even believe he had a change of
heart no i just felt more stupid
oh
i don't i don't believe it for a second
i just think he didn't get caught yeah
people
if
i think
if a negative consequence doesn't happen
from a choice a bad choice you've made
you're not going to do it you're not
going to change your thoughts until it
affects you negatively so if that
teacher
never got caught nothing bad ever came
in they're still going to do it even
though it is
bad
and i i think the older you get the more
you see people's life choices that catch
up to them
but like there's a lot of [ __ ] that i
did when i was younger because
like that i didn't do because i knew the
consequence like my dad caught me
smoking weed once in high school he
cried
bruh said not my baby girl yeah that was
a crazy thing
he thought i was a stoner
life was over but i i smoked weed once
and i caught like
like they
like the only reason they had they my
friends had a picture of me doing it was
because i didn't like it and so the
picture was the weed and then me going
and then that's when my dad sees this
picture he's like my baby's a stoner
like no dad your life is over put you in
rehab now i just wanted to try i heard
the food tasted good
but like i didn't like it anyways it
wasn't my thing but like oh my god i
oh my gosh i i felt so guilty i felt so
bad yeah and like
that it changed like you did something
you had a negative effect think about it
i'm sorry dad
i'm sorry
i didn't mean it
it was just one time thing she's okay
now she's fine living her life out here
yeah
still my brain flipping
right
tom so
but
another thought here
you're describing a world harlem the
urban world
gone yeah
you but you made visits when you were
young you knew the south as well didn't
you did you you you went back to the
south when you were young from time to
time i said back to the south because as
i recall you were born in the south yeah
like
new york went to new york yeah uh well i
i think this was courtesy the marine
corps which happened to locate the boot
camp in south carolina but what about
camp lejeune and north carolina so what
i'm getting at is you were of the
generation that saw jim crow with your
own question no question
okay
so well here's
let me read you a quotation this is from
an article that got a lot of attention
in the atlantic a couple of years ago
called the case for reparations
by tan nahisi coates
quote
white supremacy is a force so
fundamental to america smash or pass
[Music]
smashing fast
he's a black man i'm kidding pass i
think he's kind of cute he's attractive
he's attractive smash
where you at
sorry i know this is serious make light
of the mig light of the moment
that it is difficult to imagine the
country without it
reparations is the price we must pay to
see ourselves squarely close quote
and tom sowell who actually saw jim crow
with his own eyes and experienced it
responds how
it would be nice to know his uh
evidence for what he said
just to be old-fashioned about it
no it was a rotten system
but i don't know how how we get from
that to reparations
i mean
what we see in the united states in
terms of the bad things you see all
around the world
if you were to give reparations to
everyone whose ancestors had been slaves
i suspect that you would have to give
reparations to more than half the entire
population of the globe
slavery was not confined to one set of
races i suspect that most of the people
who either slaves or slave owners around
the world were neither white nor black
i mean this was this was a universal
curse of the human species africa
the middle east asia
and and it continued elsewhere
so
i can understand that because if you
give
if you give reparations to
black people
what about
overseas the jews
you have to reference reparations of
them the holocaust you give reparations
to them it's like then
those are the ones i'm off the top of my
head but there's other areas it's like
and
ireland had it too actually it was uh i
don't know if it was i think they called
it
indentured servants but if you look at
like the life expectancy it was lower
than slaves wow it was
yeah like it happened everywhere and
like
for
for a black person to say like okay
yes i understand that
reparations would be needed for
everybody so like
for
i'm trying to like say it right
it's like
you
it's hard to say like
well everybody should get reparations
like well
this happened that happened and this is
different it was like it's the same
situation because my mom would say that
to me she will always bring up the
holocaust i'm like
it's different
but it's not
if
if
the world
gave reparations to every single race
that was
done wrong then there it would be more
than just black people and that's
if you're not open to understanding that
is that you're just going to be like no
like
we need it we need it we need it but
it's like
we we don't we don't necessarily need it
because if you depend on it you're going
to be
sitting and waiting for that to come
your whole life and stay in the same
situation that you were in your whole
life waiting for someone to
give you reparations
for something that happened
many many years ago when it's like if
you want better for your life
i've literally thought of kim kardashian
if you want better get up and go to work
if you want better like you can choose
better but it's not
it's just not
like taught to us that you can choose
but i don't say it's not taught to us
but it's more so
that it's
less taught to us like you can you can
choose to do better with your life you
don't have to
follow in the footsteps of everybody
that came before yes they may have done
this done that but you don't have to
choose that life to have a better life
and
yeah no and you know what's oh my gosh
you know it's crazy that
i i hate talking about this because it
just like
i don't clamps
no but like you realize not all slaves
and slave owners had like a bad
relationship it was wrong absolutely but
like there were accounts of like slaves
slave owners or slaves being very loyal
to their slave owners even after slavery
ended like there's accounts of like a
kid that was like the slave owner's son
and um
the son um
like was a drunk and all the slaves like
took care of him even after slavery was
abolished
because it wasn't as simple as like like
if you're born into a family that has
slaves right they can't just let them go
free because then like they'll be all in
poverty like how would they exist in
society like there's writings of people
saying i think this is a terrible
institution but i don't know what to do
and you know what i'm saying yeah and i
don't i'm not like i'm not trying to
take that away like it was wrong like
absolutely but like it wasn't
there were there were accounts on both
sides it wasn't like every slave owner
was like a terrible person and the
problem is when you look at history you
have to look at it as the side of the
oppressor
that's what they always say if you
really want to understand history
it's interesting you say that there's a
video i saw
and um
it was the this i forgot who was
interviewing but it was a group of white
people sitting down and they were like
i don't i don't know what why people
think that
like
slaves were in chains and this that the
third and they were treated badly
because
my
grandparents or like
my parents had slaves but they were
treated like they were regular people
and i'm like how can how can you say
that when da da like you don't know it's
like i don't know either i don't know
where i'm only i only know what was
taught to me and what was taught to me
was
the
bad side of it and now it's like was
there
was there certain situations where
um
where
slaves were
treated
correctly or treated as equal and it's
like if i say that
which i just did it's like how can you
say that you're you're black
you don't support it's like i i like you
just i know it's bad like yes there were
situations but i'm like thinking like
were there other were there better
situations because like how can you
be
beaten
treated like the scum of the earth and
when you're free
you go back it's like
it doesn't make sense well because some
people went back to work for them
because it's like okay like the only
reason i know this is because i read
this
uh us like a kid that was like born in
slavery guys people in the comments
probably will know who he was like i
think he died around the 20s or 30s
maybe but like whenever he was alive he
was like born as a slave and he he just
gave his like life's experience and part
of it was he was talking about how like
the slaves were very loyal to that owner
because like they all really liked him
and like took care of the sun
and like um
i don't it just wasn't
and like even after slavery was over
they all stayed because they were just
loyal to him because if you're born as a
guy like who inherits a plantation if if
you let everybody just go they're going
to be in poverty how would they exist in
society yeah that's what that's what and
the only reason i know that is because i
read the this guy's diary where he
talked about that and the slave owner is
talking about like i think this is a
horrible institution
but
if i let everybody go they're gonna
they're gonna be in a worse situation
yeah
but you don't think about that yeah and
because even me saying this makes me
nervous
because i'm not i'm not sweating right
now i'm like jesus no because i'm not
i'm not trying to say it was good in any
way it was a terrible institution but
yeah
it was and
what they're talking about right now
welfare
i in my eyes from what they're saying
it's a terrible institution because it's
changed the trajectory of
people
and it's it's like but what
what can you do you can't pull out the
rug off from underneath someone right
now that is depending on it until
there's like steps to it's like when a
child is nursing you got to take steps
to
this
uh what's the word to
take them away from what they've known
for so long to start feeding them with
the body you just can't be like oh i'ma
pop you off and put a bottle in your
mouth like you don't need this anymore
but it's like
they're going to go into shock and not
know what to do and
i don't know i think that people face
consequences quicker they come up with
solutions quicker
so for example did you know anyone
during covid that didn't work because
the government was giving them money
yes i knew so many people
but the second they stopped with the
payments a lot of them got a job real
quick that is true that is true they
figured it out and i just think like
when it starts to affect your life you
just start thinking of solutions
no i don't i don't know the answer i'm
not i'm not a policymaker
or maybe let me know in the comments
long after
uh it was abolished in the western
countries all right let me try this uh
sticking with tana he see codes
it's shelby talk shelby steel talks
about white guilt and in tana he's he
coach you get this is the thing i used
to feel so guilty for being white oh my
god this is this is a thing this is such
a thing when i was younger especially
when i was like in high school because i
was just pushed so much that like white
people are bad white people this
that was like i don't know d have you
heard of that or no white guilt yeah
i've yeah i've heard of it
but i'm
i've never talked to it
i've never talked about it to a white
person to be like what do you think
about white girls yeah because when
they're like talking about all the stuff
that white people did like in schools
and stuff that was bad i'm like
but then i was like i'm not even from
the u.s i'm from my parents my
grandparents are from lithuania she's
like i'm not even technically i wasn't
even there
yeah i don't know who did that but
not the lithuanians it was in me
almost the counterpart of that
a kind of
african-american claim against the white
guild
and this seems it
beginning with the abolitionists even
beginning before the civil war
you see almost every generation there's
some expression
that
racism and slavery shall because of the
sick correctly of course the sin of
slavery is so deeply and it's something
we still live with how do we expiate it
how do we get past it is there something
we can do to relieve ourselves of this
legacy oh i think you should repeat it
if you were a slave owner i i don't see
a reason why you should feel differently
on the other hand
i can't get over the idea of a
apologizing for what b did
okay uh even when they're contemporaries
much less
when
one is dead and the other's alive
all right i mean scalia i remember
saying you know that uh i i i i owe no
man anything
because uh people who look like me
caught did something to people look like
him
okay so just get past it
get to work yeah all right tom sowell's
view is get an education stay married
and do your job
roughly yeah all right charles murray
i'm taking you used to write a column
every so often called random thoughts on
the
scene and so i'm giving you a little
little snippets here of the passing
scene as in our final questions charles
murray in his 1984 book losing ground
and charles murray writes about
discussions in academia and government
about the effort to close the gap again
between african americans and whites
quote
1984 quote whites had created the
problem it was up to whites to fix it
and there was very little in the
dialogue that treated blacks as
responsible actors close quote has that
changed no it is not
all right
on on we go to the passing scene your
friend your longtime friend walter
williams now we come to current politics
the bottom line is that president donald
trump does not have the personal
character that we would want our
children to imitate but
save his misguided international trade
policies has turned out to be a good
president
tom
i think his policies have been by and
large have been policies that were far
better than that of previous democratic
or republican administrations
so
i go by the consequences okay i mean
he he hasn't produced the right rhetoric
but the fact is that uh uh unemployment
among low-income people black hispanic
included uh i i
is a level that is far lower than it's
been in decades
i will say this
about
donald trump
he
he ran the country not as a politician
as a
from a business standpoint and that's
something that he's
good at
and
i that quote that that man said
about his character traits and what he
has
said the inappropriate things he has
said like yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't
want my child to
look like i want to say that i want to
do that just like donald trump like no
his character traits in that sense like
no
but
the policies and the things he
implemented in the country
during his presidency
can't argue with them he you know
i mean it's crazy
nobody painted him as a bad guy when he
was in the media
for all those years everyone loved him
when he was in the media like on tv yeah
rappers brought him into like videos he
wasn't sherlock holmes
people loved donald trump until he was
trying to like do something for society
honestly
yeah
and
the media
from
from
my like from what i saw that
it painted
a lot of things like incorrectly
about what he did during his presidency
and
i wish
and it wouldn't probably never be like
this to where a media can honestly like
say
oh this president did this this
president did that
where do you stand like this is like the
facts
facts they're they're gonna push their
opinions push their thoughts until
jesus comes back i can make one
i could
make one on youtube we could we could
because i
i do think that things would have
been
different
if we were shown the facts like he has
done this for this community has done
this for the country he's done this with
the
countries that we are in agreement with
now
why why don't you want him in office and
a lot a lot of the people that didn't
want him in his office because he
they thought he was a certain way and
they didn't want him and it wasn't it
wasn't based off of things that he did
well then a lot of times it's one small
clip
that goes viral yeah and i'm and i'm i'm
in that record where it was like oh i
don't i don't want him after the fact i
was like
it's kind of worse now isn't it yeah i
don't think stuff has happened i'm like
joe
mr biden
miss harris where are you at
so yeah
um
uh the the the uh
the economy is booming in a way that uh
no one had predicted like
people like uh paul krugman were saying
that when trump gets in the economy is
gonna tank no
uh the economy to hit new highs
but there but but there are so many
people among the intel intelligentsia
especially who are absolutely immune to
facts it's just as if it's as if they
took their uh anti-fat shots uh every
every every year and the facts will just
not affect them so this brings us back
i can understand i mean i really can't
my understanding is limited which is why
i'm going to put this in the form of a
question i can understand the never
trumpers who don't
don't bother me with economic boom
because this man is on my television
screen every single night and i can't
stand him i can understand i can see
that impulse i can i kind of miss him
like honestly they'll say what they want
he was entertaining he was so
entertaining it was interesting he was
funny you can't
he was he was wrong okay a lot of time
he was an [ __ ] but like you remember
when he did that whether like you've
called women pigs and he's like except
like
i don't remember that he he said okay
they said to him
like it was um some fox news reporter
where she's like
okay like donald trump you have said
this about women like you've called
women pigs you've called this this and
this and he said i never said that
except rosie o'donnell
[Music]
he's a very interesting person and
yeah we just we just don't we won't dive
into this